let's talk about Robert Todd Lincoln he
was Abraham Lincoln's son and in 1863 or
64 He Slipped at the New Jersey train
depot was almost crushed by a train car
but his life was saved when a man
reached out and grabbed him pulled him
back that man's name was Edwin Booth
Booth was traveling that day with his
friend John T Ford and a year later
Edwin's brother John Wilkes Booth
assassinated Robert's father at John T
Ford's Theater Robert was a half mile
away at the White House when it happened
and that would turn out to be the
furthest he would ever be from a
presidential assassination in his
lifetime that's right three presidents
were assassinated during Robert's
Lifetime and he happened to be near all
three of them he was at the Pan American
Expo in Buffalo New York when McKinley
was assassinated and he was President
Garfield's Secretary of War and was with
him on the platform in DC and witnessed
his assassination he eventually decided
to stop hanging out with presidents oh
by the way I visited the grave of John
Wilkes Booth a few years ago and it's
customary when you visit to leave a
little copper portrait of his victim
right there on his tombstone
[Music]